>> Good afternoon everyone.
My name is Tanuja Ganu,
and I'm co-founder
and CEO of DataGlen.
Today I'm going to
present some of
the work that we have been
doing as part of the workshop
with my teams Siddhart,
Mayuri, Prabhu and Subham as
part of who helped
me in the workshop.
So, I'll talk about
multiple problems that
we have been handling.
The overall objective is
improving the yield
of energy resources,
distributed energy resources
using AI-driven approach.
So, quick context
about the problem.
So, as we know the energy
vertical is moving from
decentralized generation
and distributed
consumption to
distributed generation
and distributed
consumption phenomenon.
Where there are lot of
distributed energy resources in
the form of solar or
electric vehicles storage
which are coming in place,
and that's adding
a lot of complexity to
the entire network of the way
we generate and consume energy.
So, as effect of this there
are different types of
equipments which are getting
connected in the entire system,
like solar inverters,
battery inverters,
there could be electric vehicles.
There are different
interesting business models
and economical problems which
are being generated
as part of this.
So, what we do at
DataGlen presenters,
we do manage and monitor
different forms of
distributed energy resources.
So, as of today, we have
400 different solar sites
which are being
managed in India which
includes the metro stations,
hospitals, and other
small and large plants.
As well, we are doing
a pilot project
in Australia with
Australian utility,
where it's a combination
of solar and
storage for
200 residential homes.
So, as part of the workshop
we wanted to try out
some real-world challenges
that we are encountering by
using some other technologies
which have been developed by
Microsoft team previously,
and wanted to see how
that fits in use cases.
So, these are
the typical challenges.
So, this is where
the setup looks like.
So, there are different
types of equipment
including inverters,
battery storage,
different types of sensors,
which give additional contexts
and permission like
irradiation sensor temperature
sensor energy meter.
Typically, at
one particular site,
if I'm considering
let's say Metro site
or Hospital as
one particular site,
there will be one data logger or
DataGlen gateway which is
a single board Linux computer,
which is connecting with these
different types of equipment
and doing data collection
and analytics Edge.
It's pushing the data
in the DataGlen cloud,
and basically doing bunch
of other portfolio level
analytics at that.
But typical challenges of
IoT intermittent network
connectivity so,
most of these sites are
at remote locations.
Many a times we
observed that there is
disconnectivity of network
for hours or days at a time.
We cannot rely on
cloud-based Analytics for
low latency control responses.
So, there are interesting use
cases where we really
need a low latency
response and we
cannot expect the data to be sent
from the Edge to the cloud
and made the decision
on the cloud.
So, those are
the kind of use cases
we are going to talk
about over here.
So, the first problem that
we wanted to tackle was
intraday forecasting for
local generation and demand.
So, why this problem
is important.
So, we want to look at
optimal utilization of
distributed energy resources.
So, take an example of a house
where there is a solar,
there is a battery storage and
there is a time of use pricing.
So, solar regenerating energy at
a typical time period of lets
say, 6:00 AM to 6:00 PM.
There are constraints on
the battery storage of
how much amount of charging
and discharging can happen.
There are time of use pricing
so there are different hours of
the day which has
different pricing.
So, if we want to have
the policy to basically
reduce the overall bill
for a consumer,
what we need to do is
accurate forecasting
of local generation,
of local demand,
and then optimization to
comply with the policy.
So, typically what we
do is we do have
day-ahead forecasting,
which is based on
the historical data
from the same location.
We also take into account
multiple third party weather
forecasting services
to do the forecasting
for the next 24 hours.
How much amount of energy
that would be generated.
But many a times due to
various different
reasons including
the weather forecasting service
itself is not able to
accurate the forecast of
the weather correctly.
Or there are issues with
the equipment during the runtime,
or there could be demand spikes
because various reasons.
There could be changes during
the day there would be changes
in the actual forecasting
of a generation and demand.
So, we wanted to see how we
can do the intraday
divisions into
generation and forecasting
on Edge without going back
to the cloud computing.
So, we looked at this problem
as the regression problem,
where we are taking into
account the information from
the day-ahead forecasting for
the next few slots as
well the let's say 10:30,
I want to focus how much energy
that would be generated
for next two hours.
So, I have information
of actual generation
for last whatever
three or four hours.
We do have information about
actual generation which has
happened during those hours,
and for each of the look-ahead we
have independent
regression models.
So, here we basically we have
used existing algorithms
which includes gradient boosting,
Random Forest, and other things,
but we also wanted
to evaluate how
the Bonsai and ProtoNN regression
models work in this case.
So, the Bonsai and
ProtoNN models which
are built by MSR team.
Those were mainly
built initially for
multi-class and
multilevel classification.
Those were not evaluated
or tested on the
regression models.
So, we basically tried
those models for
the regression problems in
this case and for
each look-ahead window.
So, over 15 minute look-ahead
we have one model,
for 30 minute look-ahead
we have different model.
One interesting point to
observe here is we had
tried LSTM and other
approaches before.
But the issue with the LSTM
model is if you are doing
the immediate look-ahead it gives
you good prediction accuracy,
but let's say if you want to
look-ahead after one hour,
you have to fill
in the information
in between with
your predicted information,
and if there is a error it just
propagates and
exponentially increases
the error in the problem.
So, we wanted to have
the independent model so
that that problem is
tackled over here.
So, these are some of the results
from Bonsai and ProtoNN,
along with the existing
approaches that we had studied.
So, on left-hand side
we are showing
the root-mean-squared error
on each of the slot.
So, x-axis, it shows
slots for different
look-ahead windows.
So, one slot look-ahead two
slot look-ahead store liquid.
As we can expect
for the immediate
look-ahead the
root-mean-square-error is low,
so the accuracy is better
for immediate slots.
As we go along for
these slots accuracy
slightly decreases,
but interestingly the
root-mean-squared error Bonsai and
ProtoNN is lower than
Random Forest and gradient
boosting in this case.
It's consistent or comparable
in the case of six,
seven and eight hours
look-ahead time slots as well.
If we look at the model sizes
on the right-hand side,
this is the log scale.
So, in case of
Bonsai and ProtoNN,
it's using 4.5 kB of model size,
whereas the XG Boost was
using close to 500 KB
of model size and
Random Forest was
using close to I think
two megabyte of model size
for the same kind of results.
So, it gives significant
reduction in the model size
while keeping
the accuracies consistent.
So, in this case we use
60-days training data and
10 days test data over
multiple different inverters,
multiple different locations
and did the results.
Visual dimension relatively
also around 35 seconds.
So, here is a quick demo on this.
So, we are looking at
individual look-ahead slots with
different models which are built.
So, the training is
done on the clouds,
the moderates are deployed on
the Raspberry Pi which
is sitting there.
So, this is the box.
Basically the evaluations
of the results
are performed on
multiple different locations.
So, I'll just go to the demo link
to give a quick demo
of how it works.
So, basically it's showing
that we do have
a day-ahead forecasting,
and depending upon
the actual generation,
the next eight slots forecasts
keeps on changing.
So, on the days where
either because of
the equipment failure or
because of the weather changes,
if there are variations
which are needed then it
would accurately
predict the NXP hours,
and the optimization,
downstream optimization would
basically work accordingly.
So, basically, till
the end of the day it
would keep on changing
the prediction accuracies.
So, the advantage over here is,
the models are compressed
so it can easily fit on
the lower footprint,
and provide the fast inference.
So, it's tacking
around 10 milliseconds
of time for the inference
in this case.
So, the second problem that
we wanted to look at is
predictive maintenance
for different
types of energy equipment.
So, based on the study,
there are different types of
maintenance issues
or costs which are
associated with different
equipment in the solar plants.
So, according to EPRI study
it shows that 50 percent of
the costs on the O&M are
associated with the inverters.
So, we wanted to look at
inverters as equipment and
how the downtimes issues which
are because of inverters.
So, this is the data collected by
our own monitoring system.
So, there are
two manufacturers A and B.
So, for manufacture A
we have a 81 inverters,
and the mean downtime is
two percent in the manufacture A,
whereas in manufacture
B it's around 4.52
percent and there is
a long tail on both the cases.
So, it's important
that we identify
the issues for fixing
the downtime as well
as for the warranty
enforcement cases so that
the manufacturer can
replace in case of issues.
So, here actually
the problem statement
is alert the engineer
at least two to four
hours in advance before
the actual downtime
by reducing the number
of false alarms.
So, for every individual
inverters we have a bunch
of parameters that we get from
the individual inverters,
which include different
voltages, currents,
and temperature, and
other parameters.
So, looking into this
we actually extended-
Use approach which is
being used by MSR team for
looking at predictive maintenance
for other industrial
applications.
So here, we are looking at 120,
so two hours window and
sliding off 15 minutes.
So, we're trying to look
ahead in two ours,
so what we do is,
we do a feature
sampling to identify
that taking these individual
data points in case.
So, let say if there is
a downtime at 11:10,
so we consider a two-hour
window before that,
and try to check whether
in this two-hour window,
are we able to predict
that there is going to be
a downtime after
two hours or four hours.
So, we have done
different types of
feature engineering to do
extracting statistical
features and
FFT features along
the sliding window of
120 minutes and stride of 15.
These features can be efficiently
computed on the edge
using online algorithms.
The challenge was data is very
skewed or imbalance
so we had to do
downsampling on the positive
or the right data so that
we are able to take
equal amount of the negative
and positive examples.
These are some of
the early results.
I think we need to do
a lot more experiments on this,
but these are the early results
where we're able to get
a 90 percent recall while keeping
the false alarm rate
at 20 percent.
So by 90 percent,
this is equivalent to 97.4 hours
of downtime that can be avoided
or proactively addressed.
Since the models, which are
used decision-based models.
The model is interpretable,
so it helps in troubleshooting
as well as for
warranty enforcement.
The last thing that
I wanted to show
was the third problem
in solar case.
Most of the inefficiencies
are because of
the soiling or the dust
which gets accumulated
on the panel.
So, that basically adds
to a significant amount
of inefficiencies in the amount
of energy that can be generated.
So, this is the data across
230 inverters from
our own dataset.
So, as we see that
the panels are not clean.
After three weeks, it gets
close to eight percent
of reduction in
overall energy generation.
So, it basically accounts
to eight percent of,
close to eight percent
of soiling losses.
So again, we wanted to model
this problem as the
regression problem.
So, here what we
are trying to do is
a retrofit on how much amount of
energy that should have been
generated given
the observable parameters.
So, the observable parameters
are solar radiation,
module temperature,
ambient temperature,
and the time of day.
We're trying to predict
how much amount of energy
that should have been generated,
and looking at
the residual analysis.
We do have a patent application
submitted on this already.
So, we look at the residual
patterns and there are
different types of
losses which are
exhibit in different
types of patterns.
So, if in case of soiling losses,
we see that instead of
residuals being random,
they have very nice pattern.
When cleaning is done,
it goes positive and overtime
it comes negative.
Based on that, we can also
quantify how much is
the soiling losses exactly.
So, we do have existing gradient
boosting regression models which
are supplied on the edge,
which is getting
close to 20 KB of model sizes.
We do experiments on
Bonsai and ProtoNN and
we wanted to see if
those can be applied
to further get
the reduction in model sizes.
Interestingly, we have not
reached the accuracies
of what gradient boosting
and random forest are giving
using Bonsai and ProtoNN,
and we did a lot of
variations on those,
and try to understand why
those are not reaching there.
So, here's a quick observation
where the actual data
looks like this.
So, there are two features
which are most important,
X-axis is the radiation,
Y-axis is model temperature and
Z-axis is the actual power.
So, there is a linear
correlation or there are
good correlations between
some high-level attributes
where there is
a scatter which is seen
in the original data,
which is being picked up by
ensemble models and
by weak classifiers.
But whereas Bonsai being
a strong predictor,
it's able to predict the
linear function correctly but
not beyond the scatter
which is predicted by
the weak classifies,
it start picking up those.
So, it reaches 196 of r
squared within one depth
tree and very fast.
But from that 0.96 to.98,
it's not able to reach.
>> Is it because Bonsai
and ProtoNN are more
geared towards classification
problems rather than regression?
>> I think this is mainly because
of the weak classifiers.
So, one thing is definitely
in classification these kind
of cases would be
directly avoided.
These problems would not be
there in classification.
We first time tried those
on regression problems.
But it is fitting well on
our first regression problem
where there are,
I think, such kind of scatters.
So, I think there is
a very peculiarity of
this problem where there are
two features which
are very dominant,
and there are other
features which have impact,
but those other features
are not getting captured
in some sense that these kinds of
models because they
are low-depth models,
and they are designed not to
be working in the ensemble form.
But in case of decision trees
or random forest,
even in random forest
it's requiring 250 random
as in the ensembles to pick
up those weak classifiers.
Which means that most
of the classifiers are
actually picking
the strong signal
and not the weak signals
in some sense.
So, these are some next steps
on all these three problems.
On the first problem,
I think we would evaluate Bonsai
and ProtoNN on more datasets,
and we would be putting
it in deployment for
the pilot sites.
For the preventive maintenance
case, we have tried,
basically on one
particular manufacturer,
so we want to replicate and
see if the similar
type of features
are applicable in
other manufacturers models.
Also, we wanted to see
that for doing a weighing
of downtime base on the- So,
there are certain downtimes which
are 10 minutes downtime,
there are certain
downtimes which are
like two hours or
four hours of downtime.
So, can the predictor
do the weighing of
downtimes based on the
amount of impact it creates?
Also, increased the focus window.
So, right now, we are
looking at two to four hours
forecast window and we
increase it to one day.
Does it make sense?
Does it really pick
up the signal day
ahead in advance?
So, those are the kind of
things that we wanted to look at.
In auto cleaning control,
we would like to continue
with the evaluation of
ProtoNN to see if for
these kind of problems,
if ProtoNN would be able to
has multiple prototypes.
So, if those
prototypes can pick up
those weak points
or in some sense,
anomalies or outliers which
are already present in the data.
So, those are the next steps
that we would like to try.
I would like to thank you for
the entire support from
different teams in MRS, Harsha,
Prateek, Naga, Vivek, Aditya,
all of them have helped
significantly in improving
and trying out various approaches
where it's not working.
We would like to continue
with the collaboration
in future as well. Thank you.
>> So, I have a question.
It seems that most of
the things they're doing
are actually pretty
I wouldn't say simple but
pretty straightforward
time series,
signal processing kind of task.
For which, I feel like
machine learning type of thing,
just like Jammer you're
throwing at this problem.
Seem like classical, I'm not
a signal processing person
but if I think of classical
signal processing techniques for
estimation detection should
be much more compact and
much better than throwing
machine learning.
So I don't know if
you've any thoughts
about those kinds of things.
It might actually get
a much complicated
because you know it's
a time series problem,
you know the time
series signature
of what the pattern looks like.
Say, I'm looking for
a square, we're or
looking for a sine wave.
Well, I'm not expert in
it, but I'm pretty sure,
you ask signal processing,
then I'll say, "Okay,
this is a carbon filter block,
or match filter or something."
So, I'm not sure why
machine learning for this.
>> So, we have looked
at few approaches for
signal processing.
I think one thing
is in this entire,
the way the equipments
are working,
the signatures are not
common across all
different manufacturers.
Signatures are not-
so the kind of
signatures which we are looking
into this residual patterns,
so those are the signatures which
we are doing post-processing and
based on the analysis that
we have done from the data,
we are now identifying those are
the processing
which are required.
So, having a common generic model
which is applicable
for different types of
equipment and different
manufactures' equipment,
I think is a challenging
task over here,
and that's where
machine learning approaches
like this coming in this.
>> So, I guess there
is two parts of this.
One is actually is talking
to the students working
on the similar thing.
I think there's
two parts of it. One is
the signature synthesis for
which machine learning might
be the right approach.
Then there's the actual matching
which you want run at the edge.
Doing machine learning at
the edge may not
make sense for this,
you actually do
the complex machine learning
to run a time series signature.
You may actually want to split
a board like an
offline-online process.
Like what runs online might
not be machine learning,
what runs offline might
be machine learning.
Maybe that's
a better architecture
for some of these applications.
>> Yeah. So, I think definitely
I would like to evaluate
those approaches.
But even in this case,
that is the baby you're
trying to segregate it.
So, the kind of
complex tasks which require
additional third-party
information as well
as if you start looking
at the head forecasting,
we don't want to push the head
forecasting on the edge
because that requires multiple
other sources information,
and looks at much larger
amount of data from
multiple years and
seasonalities and other things.
So, that information,
those are the kinds
of things which are
computed in Cloud.
But when we finally push
that information on the edge,
the issue is that we
need to make the signal,
make this inference
every few minutes,
or every five minutes,
every 15 minutes.
At that time, we have
to otherwise call,
if we're using
machine learning models,
we have to call back to
the Cloud and get
that information.
So, we're trying to separate out
the problem in the sense that
whatever requires
additional information
and larger computation,
that's pushed into the cloud,
whereas a very small problem,
even in case of
optimization we do
a head optimization based on
the day ahead information,
we do the optimization, and
only optimization revision
works on the edge.
So in some societies,
the classification of what
would run in the Cloud,
but I think I would
need to look into,
if there are other
similar processing kind
of techniques which would
be helpful for this and
not looked into that.
>> Okay. Thank you for your time.
>> Yeah. Thanks.